yeah welcome to this video playing young
gun from the US and down
yeah let's transpose to a Queen's Gambit
mm yeah let's play the regular Queen's
Gambit or let's see what done line is
coming up with Bishop F visually samne
oh of course not not the Queen yeah the
bishop F online I played for many years
the 97 line now it's um it's the modern
way to play this Knight B to d7 are late
h5 hmm that's a bit unusual but maybe
you can do that really
hmm don't really believe that the
question has some how to refute that g4
hmm not sure if this is so clear-cut a
g4 takes takes h5 mmm
I thought thought Bishop c7 take C 7 and
then G 4 but he's got Knight f4 just
doing this carry cancer maneuver g4
takes d5 takes h5 mmm
this probably isn't term isn't clear at
all yeah like him at the end I drove it
back I didn't expect him to take on g3
witches could the obvious mistake I
really I thought you would of course
keep the night there and play c6 all
night yeah c6 probably now he just has
got trouble with the H file I wouldn't
if I would have known that you could
take on g3 I will play it instantly
g-force to make it more difficult for
him to play f5
so Bishop d3 or Quincy tool and let's
start with this Bishop d3 now
threatening to take on g6 hmm no let's
just um pile up on the hand eh file
maybe there was some direct way but this
really looks okay there's some ways to
really quickly lose now b6
should I just double okay let's just
double I threatened Bishop d6 no
actually okay
drop back hmm yeah how to break through
now
should I go eform and E for Queen d2 or
takes Knight takes e5 f of Queen d2 too
many too many tempting moves first
yeah then if I've to get captain off the
sea phone
Queen d2 as now it's not clear that
creates excess Sun so great maybe I need
more firepower Queen d2 and 92 f1
something like this one good thing is
that jeebies barely am able to move
anything that--some it's really a
passive setup oh no this this uh this is
hard to believe I go here okay that's an
exchange but can I win more now come on
let's let's let's do this
shudder should be enough really
Bishop g6 is the simple way to go or is
there some some win Queen edge some Jegs
oh isn't there mate finished application
this actually is a mate and after that
check
check age 7 check King g 6h for checking
your phone look G 7 check King F for g3
mate it isn't made it I took took a long
time but it is a checkmate King f8 or g8
is just two checks h8 h 7 and mate he
needs to go to e8 to e 8 and then I hope
I saw this correctly that it leads to a
maid on f4 at the end Keaney 8 Bishop d6
King f8 check King g7 rook h7 checking
g6 yeah we get it on the board
check check check
and g3 made this was was my calculation
and it was right for once
it took a while but it was right g3 made
at the end I could have taken the
exchange here with Bishop g6 this was
also this was a simple way but this is
really a major yeah it is made Queen f7
and Bishop g6 just wins wins the
exchange you this is the does the simple
way to to do it to scrap this yeah well
I saw the assaulter mate and it's it's
unavoidable this is the easier checkmate
and the problem is here yeah that the
difference is that you can actually take
the bishop
but there's yeah exactly this yeah this
made that I that I saw quite nicely on
this this Knight is controlling
controlling f3 yards now I screwed it up
this is controlling f3 this is
controlling e 2 and E 4 so it's really
nice this rook is not even not necessary
yeah thanks for watching this